the iconic lead of peewee's playhouse
Paul Rubens passed away at the age of 70
after privately living with cancer for
several years he was preceded in death
by many other actors from The Beloved
show these are the playhouse Legends you
may not know passed away during the
first season of Pee-wee's Playhouse Mrs
Steve was one of the more frequent
guests invited or otherwise at Pee Wee
Herman's Swanky pad Mrs Steve was
essentially a snoop and gossip often
sauntering up to the playhouse with bad
vibes and a floral dress I was not
I just happened to be passing by your
door the character was played by actress
Shirley Stoller who enjoyed a
decades-long career in Hollywood her
first major appearance on screen came in
the movie the honeymoon Killers she
later raised eyebrows as a Nazi prison
commandant in seven Beauties a role that
garnered her major media attention by
way of the New York Times other credits
included Charlie's Angels Kojak
Desperately Seeking Susan and Law and
Order Stoller died on February 17 1999 a
matter of weeks before her 70th birthday
of heart failure after a lengthy illness
the king of cartoons was a fixture at
the playhouse descending upon peewee's
place with a film projector or antique
television in tow every episode his
mission besides ruling over cartoon land
was to share a classic cartoon with the
playhouse gang and all of the children
at home King cartoon as he was
originally called was actually played by
two different black actors Gilbert Lewis
and William Marshall Lewis was the first
king of cartoons having filled the role
during the first season of Pee-wee's
Playhouse he worked steadily before and
after his stint on Playhouse appearing
in films like Candyman and Gordon's War
he died in 2015 at the age of 79.
Marshall meanwhile may be the best
remembered King wearing the cartoon
crown for the show's Final Four Seasons
he was well known long before his Peewee
days having played the title role in the
iconic black exploitation film Blacula
as well as its sequel scream Blacula
scream he died in 2003 at the age of 78.
Phil Hartman may be best known for his
iconic work on Saturday Night Live but
he actually got his start at the
Groundlings alongside Paul Rubens from
there he jumped feet first into peewee's
wild world as Captain Carl a rough and
tumble sea captain in Reuben's original
Stage production of the Pee-wee Herman
show Hartman also made an appearance as
a reporter and co-wrote Reuben's
breakout film effort the Tim Burton
directed Pee-wee's Big Adventure before
reprising his role as Carl for the first
season of playhouse from there his
career exploded on SNL where he came to
be known for impersonating the likes of
notable celebrities like Charlton Heston
and creating characters like the
unfrozen caveman lawyer Hartman was a
fixture on the show for eight seasons
from 1986 to 1994 and regularly appeared
on beloved shows like news radio and The
Simpsons sadly Hartman was murdered by
his wife Bryn omdahl in 1998 when he was
just 49. omdahl died by Suicide soon
after confessing to the crime the couple
had been married since 9 1987 and had
two children together the history of
peewee's playhouse can't be written
without mentioning John Paragon the
actor and comedian was a frequent
collaborator of Paul Rubens and their
working relationship can be traced back
to the Inception of the Pee-wee Herman
character in the late 70s when they were
both members of the Groundlings comedy
group peewee's Playhouse saw Paragon
play zombie the genie a disembodied head
he appeared in most episodes to Grant a
wish to PeeWee even though the results
didn't always go according to plan
zombie even had a fun catchphrase
elsewhere Paragon voiced Terry the
pterodactyl a dinosaur who was afraid of
thunderstorms sadly Paragon died in
April 2021 at the age of 66 but the news
didn't become public knowledge until
months after it occurred furthermore the
autopsy reports revealed that heart
disease stemming from alcohol abuse was
the cause of death
peewee's Playhouse wouldn't exist
without Paul Rubens the comedian who
portrayed Pee-wee Herman on the Beloved
children's show and Beyond Rubens played
the childlike fun-loving Playhouse owner
throughout the series entire run and
eventually took the character everywhere
from Hollywood to World Wrestling
Entertainment do you mind if I call you
pee anything you like
[Applause]
Peewee is an undeniable icon of popular
culture and his legacy will undoubtedly
live on forever in fact Reuben's
dedication to the character led many
people to believe that there was no
difference between the real man and his
fictional Persona as he told interview
magazine I spent a lot of time and
energy making sure that people thought
Peewee was a real person my billing was
always Pee-wee Herman as himself
Reuben's performance as Pee-wee Herman
made him a beloved figure in the eyes of
many people which is why the comedian's
fandom was heartbroken to learn about
his death on July 30th 2023. Rubens died
aged 70 after a multi-year battle with
cancer which he kept hidden from the
public until the sad news came to light
foreign